the father of a missing Iowa college
student believes his daughter may have
left willingly with someone she knows 20
year-old Molly Tibbets was last seen
taking her daily jog nearly three weeks
ago
Crimestoppers says it's received about
500 leads in the case
Adriana Diaz is in Brooklyn Iowa where
she spoke with Timothy's parents
Adrianna good morning good morning this
printshop is the nerve center in the
community's effort to find Molly Tibbets
they've made thousands of items
including buttons posters and t-shirts
her parents told us that these images
give them comfort because they're in
love with their daughter's smile molly
Tibbets family describes her as a light
who loves to lift others this video from
a 2016 faith event is being shared
online in her hometown where her parents
got a phone call Sunday they'd been
dreading investigators found a body but
they couldn't yet confirm if it was
their daughter what was your reaction
terror investigators soon announced the
body was not Tibbets but 20 year old
Sadie Alvarado who was found on the side
of a road in Lee County Iowa we
immediately when we found out thought
about that family and the tragedy that
they went through is there anything you
want to say to her family or the people
looking for her that is hopefully find
her
Wayne Cheney who lives near the search
area says he's been questioned by
investigators at least five times about
Tibbets the farmer has several
convictions including stalking and
harassment charges and seven other cases
have been dismissed well there was an
FBI guy who he was just here not too
long ago this morning yeah what did he
want me to do a polygraph chest or
something and I said no I'm not doing it
what do you think happened
it's totally speculation I think someone
went to the house that Molly knew or
that Molly trusted and she left with
them willingly and now they're in over
their head and they don't know what to
do Tibbits is one of more than 88,000
active missing-persons cases in the u.s.
her search continues to make national
headlines people see in Molly
own daughters their own girlfriend their
own sister
I think it struck a chord with people
that you know this could be happening to
me right now to my family molly is more
than Robert Tibbets daughter at his
wedding earlier this year she was his
best man if she is watching this what do
you want to say to her
just hang on pie we're gonna come get
you
everybody's looking we also spoke to
Molly's boyfriend who says she is a
fighter and he believes she's still
alive police still haven't made any
arrests or named any suspects and the
reward is now more than two hundred and
seventy-seven thousand dollars Vlad Wow
all of us holding out hope yeah well I
was hoping that she is okay yeah the dad
is right where he says everybody's
looking for you and as a family you just
have to hold out hope until you have
news that says you it tells you
something one way or the other but
everybody's hoping that other body that
they found I was curious so there are
two women who are missing out turns out
she apparently had a fight with her
boyfriend jumped out of the car and now
that's a totally separate case that's
under investigation
scary yes indeed Adriana Diaz thank you
so much for that reporting